erken dat de Islam
1 geweldige ideologie is
die haat en terreur met zich meebrengt en dus niet
bij Nederland hoort
2 sluit onze grenzen onmiddellijk
voor asielzoekers en immigranten
uit Islamitische landen
ZEG schengen op en voer weer eigen grenscontroles in
3 begin
met het ontmantelen van de instituties van de Islam
zoals moskeeën en begin bijvoorbeeld
met het sluiten van al die moskeeën
die buitenlandse financiering krijgen
en we hebben bijvoorbeeld die en het Turkse ministerie
van godsdienst zaken de baas is en niet wij
4 sluit iedereen op
die met geweld dreigt of geweld gebruikt
of zet ze ons land uit
en Pak die honderden aanhangers
en die duizenden sympathisanten van de jihadistische
beweging in Nederland
als het moet preventief op
en 5 voorzitter
vraag alle scholen
kranten media om 1 Mohammed cartoon te tonen
niet om te provoceren
om te laten zien
dat wij nooit wijken voor bedreigingen en geweld
en dat wij trots en fier achter onze vrijheid staan
wij hebben nog 1 boodschap
aan al die moslims in Nederland
die onze vrijheid
onze democratie
en onze kernwaarden niet respecteren
die de regels van de Koran
belangrijker vinden
dan op boodschappen en hen is wegwezen
vertrek naar 1 islamitisch land
dan kun je genieten van Islamitische regels
dat zijn hun regels
maar niet onze
dit is ons land
niet uw land maar ons land